I think a lot of Republicans would vote
for RFK as well but they're not going to
for a very shallow reason I think he's
got a serious disadvantage because of
his voice which sounds very shallow but
I think if he had the same ideas and he
was in a different body he would be he
would perform much better yeah the voice
is a big part it's like a reverse JFK
Nixon it's a it's a talking job so
that's that's a good point of all the
presidential uh announcements that I've
heard so far from DeSantis and Trump I
mean Trump's presser was pretty
lackluster too if you listen to rfk's
because I listen to his entire like it
was 75 90 minutes on Twitter spaces and
it was phenomenal it was really really
good so yes I I agree with you that like
there will be superficial analysis that
says ugh I can't like what's up with
this dude's voice but if you actually
listen to the content of his words it's
incredible
to be fair even though he does say some
good things like he's still a Democrat
he's still on the left he's not a social
conservative so like as a conservative I
would not vote